[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to hot boxing with
Mike Tyson I'm Evan Britton and I'm Mike
Tyson well it's good to have you here
Mike anytime for my man Iron Mike thank
you very much hell yeah man well we got
these gloves for you to see you next
time it was official hell yeah man hey
man Mike Tyson I've been a fan of Mike
Tyson system beginning some of them
coca-cola commercials and I was the
healthy Cola Pepsi man was the
all-american black guy yeah I see but
you know what I see all-american black
out with a lot of commercials and stuff
yeah guys from the hood when they seen
you though they was like they was like
white people don't know that do right
there he'll do a robbery chambray and I
can say I saw a scene robberies I met a
girl I played your daughter of the
little black girl named yeah was that
one of the wars okay Mike I'm touching
that I played in a movie with you okay
how you doing yeah good is that the one
where Mike comes in
I'm trying to get my money back Bungie
package TV [ __ ] my money I'm trying to
receive my money back that's the thing
about Mike he's funny without even
trying
yeah he's funnier than some of these
comics they his timing is better than
some of these comics around here it's
true man he's hysterical naturally yeah
yeah
so what's the deal we want to know
everybody wants to know what the deal
with Richard Pryor man oh yeah you know
what Mike Richard Pryor movie man we all
love which a prior you know I mean
Richard Pryor was definitely our type of
comic you know I think credible listen
he's an incredible human being i watch
the special of him and he had one of her
meet him yes I met him on the set when
he was at Fox
Eddie Murphy no looking with that but uh
[ __ ] Harlem you're on that set yeah he
was cool might yo he's beautiful man
yeah I wish I could have met oh man hey
Mike how you don't come here talkin to
you boy I'm calling you boy you hear me
talking to you come over here
Wow yeah it's a prize no it's good red
fox show any [ __ ] box like where Fox
is a good guy go backstage we talk about
stories he took my I wouldn't used to be
younger I mean my comment used to be
good friends
Wow yeah and they hung out I guess they
both from st. Louis offense yeah and so
they used to be good friends and Easter
hustling stuff Larry kids and he left
him went to New York who the packed up
dude he got oh he went to New York he
was saying gray fox was in the joint to
where [ __ ] he's a dirty red - yeah he
was a bad guy with the hustle back in
the day - all of guys all those guys who
do every day they were singers
entertainers put them up [ __ ]
so Mike your your cast to play Richard
in an upcoming film well I was cast to
play him they then got to the movie yet
okay Mike right yes it is truly it is
okay well what what I was saying was a
yeah uh the the Richard Pryor movie you
know hopefully one day they'll get it
together but I actually played a little
bit of Richard Pryor in the Nina Simone
movie it was played by Zoe's out downer
hmm you played Richard Pryor talking to
him and he said she said son to the
ferry I met a great guy and said he's
great really not [ __ ] you say I'm
tell you i watch that stuff yeah Mike
yeah I did seeing some [ __ ] nah yeah
that was a and that was a small little
movie that was like an indie film but
you know the played a big Richard Pryor
that would be a really it would be a
thriller about him yeah that'd be
awesome
just amazing history of life he is just
amazing itself yes don't wanna see the
Mike Tyson store oh that's gonna be a
trip working on it now no but it's gonna
be a trip it's gonna be awesome dude I'm
a trip man is it Jamie Foxx yeah yeah
Mike Tyson story is crazy it's almost
it's unbelievable it's like Greek
mythology hey I'm so happy I'm still
alive I can't believe I'm still alive
breathing every [ __ ] man in the
world thought he was dying to AIDS at
least once
oh yeah hey take my fight my fight they
take my blood
like you don't got [ __ ] I think Suns
wrong yeah look at every bigot in the
world
I really believe some what's wrong with
me because I was just living my life
really fouled back then I was champion
about living my life really foul I was
really living disgusting yeah [ __ ] for
the month
ah [ __ ] it nasty [ __ ] know what guess
what Doha world is attracted to it Mike
okay
they love it alright you don't like it
but the world you know how many
[ __ ] wish they had enough heart
to be a rotten [ __ ]
oh man God die miserable lies cuz they
didn't get a chance what [ __ ]
when you living that life back then
you're right Mothe is okay yeah oh okay
you lived deeply yeah with the [ __ ]
really deep rich life man yeah you know
I did a lot of drinking it was like
being in a movie being high yeah it's
doing whatever you wanted to do buying
whatever you wanted to buy yeah yeah
trip you're kidding I came from nothing
I know that in anything we come really
well you can imagine yeah the whole here
the hold of the water the whole poor
[ __ ] well figured curried lunch getting
cut off welfare yeah they cut their life
yeah your mother tell you go outside and
she gotta talk to her yeah house look
like [ __ ] you better not have an uncle
over there they'll cut your food stamps
off no they did that we beg them to cook
give them back yeah well get them to get
them stamps back yeah where'd you grow
up my person 15 I grew up in Indiana or
what open Indianapolis
awesome yeah so the Colts are your team
coaches my team Mike Tyson no all my
homies resting yes big suites man big
suites Dominick Amy man he loves I was
incarcerated in the end
yeah Kato big sweets big sweets what did
he do he did everything
goddamn listen usually he was in he was
in the courtroom right and the lady said
you remanded back to prison Heaney and
he ran up the courtroom he sure did he
ran up the phone right all the way down
to the hoos yeah he got out of the car
they said so does the lady start talking
they said he's moving his he hated
prison [ __ ] anything with me how you
doing dominate branch are you doing go
Mike yeah Mike that's really cool man
you know and I was just checking out
some of your gear from back in the days
right
you had them you had the month that's
why I wore this jacket Sudan because I
seen you would have Sergio to Keaney
Jagger suit on when you were standing
there with your leather jacket leather
jackets them double revert to most over
like that listen Noah so crazy but being
that guy back then even after taking the
toad nonetheless doesn't matter
materialism don't matter
yeah you know don't ya know Madison will
just think I was getting nervous inside
when this stuff stuck hitting well and I
start getting money again I said really
Mike you know you're eager to take over
I hope you [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
again yeah those demons yeah I think
about that crazy [ __ ] sometimes yeah
money's a [ __ ] trust more money more
problems man
yeah keep buying the same [ __ ] over with
it right yeah I seen a [ __ ]
not enough cars that's what I'm saying
the house isn't big enough and it seemed
like if you give somebody so much you
got some money - what the [ __ ] kind of
these stuff they [ __ ] anybody hot
some [ __ ] right let me give them some
[ __ ] take it kind of make them rich yeah
yeah on the wife worker you know there's
no bounce eventually you always wind up
alone at the end I always figured that
out you always want to belong you got to
start to self back up for my seasoning
yeah it's heavy dude did you tell Mike
about the toad explain it to Mike
so the toad which might did they extract
this five Meo DMT from this toads venom
and you know DMT is ayahuasca have you
heard of any of that town man DMT
pathway so DMT we have this gland in our
brain called the pineal gland is like
your third eye oh wow and religious
scriptures the third eye Neal pine Neal
gland No oh yeah check this out Mikey
the pineal gland X is the only place in
our brain that it excretes this DMT
naturally and we get a hit of DMT when
we're forming in our mother's womb and
then on our deathbed twice in our lives
and so what's it called D M T wildest
shittin VMT
DMT that's it that's it right there
now what didn't know what is it this
look like okay go ahead finish no so
this is a psychedelic so you people have
visions people so it cures people of
depression anxiety addiction cancer all
that [ __ ] people go down to the Amazon
to do ayahuasca ceremonies with the
tribe now people are doing ceremonies
where they smoke this DMT with a shaman
and so Mike did it recent
and he smoked this stuff and it
transports you and it shows you your
whole life all your traumas that you've
experienced and it really releases you
from it all it's a real Mike listen Mike
when I first did it right I said to
myself oh [ __ ] when I hit it boom I
wouldn't a chain like this one I because
you think you're gonna die yeah you feel
that way you just go to different
chambers you see [ __ ] and uhm you think
of laughs everything left for 10-15
minutes you still come out of [ __ ] we
know you love the world you find pure
loving trust becomes your boundaries to
the gases I want that [ __ ] right now
incredible [ __ ] counter issues
scary Suki you think you're gonna die
you start can't breathe can't leave my
kids no [ __ ] [ __ ] life anything to do
I can leave right now those died and I
came out yeah he hasn't been the same
since man hasn't really been just to see
Mike how he was before that I was a dope
fiend [ __ ] I was always doing I can
stop cocaine they go like no Mike Mike a
concern oh I love this money yeah got it
Mike Twohey and and my you was not by
yourself
well let me tell you what's different
this guy it's clear that he is found
acceptance and forgiveness for himself
with the toad and it's beautiful man to
watch this guy me and Mike Tyson
both in the Marion County Jail you
remember them look with the sheriff's of
so uh judge Wapner and all them people
maybe why she wasn't even God was my
wife any of you here playing field
nobody Cato if what they sent you you
put you in one of the Diagnostics
Diagnostics amazing that cell you hear
people screaming whatever people help
but check your education and all this
[ __ ] listen you to the joint but but all
I see was a you've sent it was it was
really a youth center but what they did
was they had dudes that they had guys
that did life had lifers and stuff they
were when they were short on a time they
mix them up in the prison that's what
made it kind of bad hmm you know sounds
but it wet but I'm not gonna lie I tell
people all the time man I had some times
in there where I swear I was having a
ball I ain't gonna lie some nights when
they got the weed in there oh yeah and
everybody pulled a buckets out had a
popcorn gave me back my gambling with
the honey buns had poker games and the
TV beyond I wish I could have ran into
you when you was giving away them
thousands back in the head yeah yeah and
I used to travel with at least 100,000
on me yeah it spin the money my little
purse man we had them in person yeah
yeah and I purchased the first is their
problem from a some problem or present
charge hey what's everything okay poem
everything cool boy it's crazy back if
you could turn back in life and you
could have redone it would you have done
it anyway different tell the truth
yeah I'd have done it smarter those
people without people knowing I wouldn't
that's all this [ __ ] orgies and
Stillwater [ __ ] them though
yeah but nobody else was a nudist that's
my biggest thing that I was a kid I
girls and stuff didn't like me it's not
the [ __ ] I'm gonna be fetching famous
when I'm gonna get a lot of girls yeah
ego shed and Raven girl this girl found
out I peed in the bed she said one of
these little boys smell like lemonade on
the bus it was oh no I was on the back
because sometimes sometimes when I peed
on myself I didn't change my clothes
I'll just let it dry he'll say I'm
diggin I let that [ __ ] dry and I go on
the bus but I wanted to smell like it
cuz they was trying to bully me I was
like okay if them thugs want to run up
on me they're gonna grab a pissy [ __ ]
today I said [ __ ] walking over ready
to fight me be like oh that's a good
strategy
oh yeah dude no no no being poor wasn't
people laughed at my cold it went
thataway messin at me do your [ __ ]
clothes [ __ ] bunk I didn't understand
the [ __ ] that was about the one that's
it come with me let me show you this
[ __ ] [ __ ] just what you do with your
money you buy clothes you buy sneakers I
had no idea I was I was still planning
abandoned building with my nice clothes
getting more dirty cuz you know you have
to be a little cute smelling good ass
[ __ ] like the [ __ ] smelling good ass
[ __ ] doing bad right now where did you
guys meet
I make Mike what do we meet at happy i
YC no I wish I wish I would have made my
Saint judge to yeah we hadn't yeah
Patricia careful yeah man that was
Devils oh that was a white lady judge in
a Indiana that was locking [ __ ] up
yeah I mean rapid yeah Patricia Gifford
look it up on you I believe it I was
given a lot of time away too
it's [ __ ] up and in the end thank you
some of them are alright good guys
well you know when you black and you see
a bunch of white men you start thinking
of the law well you know somebody's
going to jail now and there's too many
white men here this is [ __ ] white
people think the crazy should they go
like this and like this you know granny
look at this it [ __ ] up imma change
then it's some weird should they do with
[ __ ] like that who white people yeah
they do do that yeah it's like [ __ ]
like trading places they do it like that
yeah really yeah they covertly yeah they
do [ __ ] like that
Trading Places pick a guy boom let me
help you out that's what they're doing
with me I think yeah I can dig I'm a
homeless guy man you know what you know
what I'm not lying I swear I believe
that can you handle it why people look
at another white guy like he's a black
dude and you ought to do thanks brother
they think you do black dude you know
you was in our seat that was some of the
roughest white boys in the world locked
up in Indiana
white people are insane murdered and
they don't [ __ ] look at all the dudes
doing the mass shootings all white
people they Indiana got some mean white
yet around I believe it man I mean some
white kids that black kids to see them
would be like I ain't [ __ ] with no
[ __ ] way [ __ ] little white
dude what you lookin at [ __ ] pills yeah
serious guy he have glasses on be real
quiet and everybody saying what's up
with you and it's they don't [ __ ] with
him and they say why I say yeah here go
there he gonna catch you while you sleep
look here man these [ __ ] Mike
Tyson gloves I got right here I'm about
to post these [ __ ] oh yeah brother my
[ __ ] know I'm sitting here with Iron
Mike yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah dude how about your your Tory
got a name a poison
funny as ish yeah I'm doing a tour right
now with some more earthquake DC young
fly I got a couple dude I'm stopping on
the road since I don't know I've been
doing stand-up comedy for 25 years more
who you working with some more yep she's
still doing the stuff doing she's doing
cool Mike yeah yeah she love you I know
that these good people know people but
some more good people I got Ralph
McDaniel video music yes good brother
big time big Ralph McDaniels video music
box my man cool DJ red alert that was
your man you remember Frankie Crocker
yes big time before he died another
little kid when he was in the radio
Frankie Crocker was a ball at huh big
time boy yeah I've never got a chance to
meet him but Frankie Crocker rocker
that's awesome
where was he in New York yeah yeah what
about a what about a club shadows you
ever been there every shadow silver
shadows shadows that was on the east
side right it's on 20 something
somewhere down there right yeah have fun
done that and Bentley that was battling
against Bentley families yeah
Bentley's how was that Finley was the
bomb yeah all the money make a lot of
gangsters in there because wood leather
shirt song that is sweating good looking
good balling huh
it's like a low-income plate that people
go by everybody look like they're
high-income you know that's great but
look at than their fly leather suits
eelskin boo that's great yeah a nugget
watches member the Bulova watch it yeah
the lawn gene really good stuff never
did me got Fisher none of them guys
didn't listen they they look they're all
a little bit ahead of me I don't get to
see him
no they got about Larry Davis you are
Tulare Larry Davis wrote me in prison he
did yeah
I gotta kill those people up in New York
police do broke me when I was in Indiana
they was trying to do a story on him I
don't know whatever happened to Larry
Davis he was the truth
I don't know he is wrote some letters
home did you ever know the real 50 cent
yeah I knew I'm living but I knew this
guy when I was a young kid like 11 years
old 50 cent yeah he's also how will you
be now like 56 in the fifth year make
you a little bit older than me who's the
real 50 70 I was born in best of me him
and a friend Darrow and stuff he was
really close friends with Darryl green
eyes no look Darryl homicide he was
really close friends with him and I was
friends with died but that's really I
knew him though that [ __ ]
Brooklyn was off the chain yeah that was
probably hard place for for a young
black man to grow up anyway you know
what I mean both of them was fatherless
you know really clear Browns of the trip
on the streets alone I'd be a man yeah
it's typical black warrior-like
mentality this i'ma do is go talk to me
any kind of way to respect me right yeah
yeah you can lose your life for some
stupid [ __ ] most kids in New York or
survivors though they know how to
survive they real really young they grew
up real real fast like if you got New
York and walk down the street and see
some kids when you if they like 10 years
old them little [ __ ] are grown
listen I would never let my kids grew up
in New Year I'm so happy always wanted
to avoid my kids from being like me yeah
that kind of life dog world yeah it's a
tough place for sure it is but you do
want them to get their ass spanked a
little bit so yeah you have to life is
real yeah you know it's it's interesting
one way toes got to break them I like my
kids can handle those guys you know
you're not gonna learn passion and
that's because the woman that you had
the kids by not really really the women
you have kids with I tell guys all the
time me like I want my son to go to the
NFL he's like well you can't go have a
baby by this model looking [ __ ] your
mama got to be a warrior to know this is
a cool show man this here with the
legendary I'm Mike Tyson yeah I talk
[ __ ] yeah it's really fun in a safe
place what's this maple wood you got
Mike called the day's maple wood that's
your [ __ ] yeah dude it's called the day
days they pretty good you know I mean
it's it's rep with a ain't no DNA on
it's all roll with honey glue ooh nice
natural I'm trying to stay in there man
I got so many kids now not just I would
have a boy it's a damn shame I gave you
so much [ __ ] [ __ ] when I was a kid
yeah was my [ __ ] thing yeah man hey I
got it brother I totally relate if I
always thought that [ __ ] Asians going
blind the bad news here man when you was
locked up tell the truth you could it
was so easy for you to sleep at night
because you had so many memories in your
head you can add a whole imagination in
your head hey that you could just sit
and think about everything that happened
and what you was gonna do when you got
out
I've been locked up before the kids too
but when I got locked up in prison that
I was older than the experience the life
being champ and all that stuff you just
learn you know if they had the best rest
in my life when I wasn't further the
most peaceful time yeah yeah really
you found man it was just like box loads
of milf I will read my mail oh really
yeah oh wow first time people sending
naked pictures and stuff then really
then eventually I met this other and man
he said Mike you don't understand cuz I
was telling when you read this letter
that's not in decide whether I should
write it back on that tell me how she
looked from the picture and they said
he's looking at rain so Mike you don't
understand these people they want to
help you listen to this if there's
anything I can do for you please let me
know do you hear that Mike is there
anything I can do for you
that means she sent money so he
eventually told me Mike actually every
one of these women for 20 bucks did you
do yeah I started getting scared cuz
this time they gonna set me up I said
he's setting me up I said this guy's set
me up some forgery cuz they got to
become too much money and so I fear this
will be a forgery right we're gonna be
[ __ ] up again and I'm getting more
time snarling right no more time not
taking more money but this is what
happened this is what happened on Evan
this is what happened the guy kept
telling he was me kept writing left
fainting with me and the girl sensing
changed watches he was fly and then
eventually the girl she came to the
prison said I want to see Mike when I'm
cousin you were like guys no idea I had
no idea what's going down but the guy
have to go see that Mike can you close
the room and see if they think of this
one I said no I can't do he eventually
got in trouble yeah we went to prison he
had to get [ __ ] at all yeah yeah she
went the whole fun I got shipped out to
another prison because of that he was oh
he milked a good chains and shoes right
this nothing what the [ __ ] you know I
mean no he does not selfish she was
right he's trying to get me to go out
there and accept the visit yeah she
called me crazy
holy
good that's a trip was it all positive
well the fan mail you're mostly positive
then you get some of them so you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you got what you deserve you and
him in another entertain you're both
[ __ ] [ __ ] they say some of those are
real black people you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you in such yeah I'm sure I mean
Jesus [ __ ] man hey but let that mean
that made me stronger than individual
Joe you know I mean look at you have to
look at that supplement and the mirror
and say this is what it is in the world
you look at yourself in the mirror this
is what it is who you really are now you
gonna accept that kind of [ __ ] you know
I mean I can't go crazy every time you
know I hear form I say [ __ ] because I'm
very familiar with that word [ __ ] you
know I mean yeah and that's what facing
racism helped me draw a little slice to
handle before you saw it be fight out
shooting after my [ __ ] calm in there
I'm not shooting no [ __ ] body no I'm
not gonna talking about issues nobody
know you [ __ ] crazy I was on that I
was another type of guy before yeah
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm just grateful I'm
here with your guys I'm so grateful [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's almost like you
sacrificed yourself to go through that
yeah so that we could have a Mike Tyson
yeah you know that you have to look at
it in that way but for sure because
that's how life that's how God is and he
used you yeah he used you in seconds and
you'd sacrificed and he used you so that
other people could learn yeah so you had
to so you have to forgive yourself
because you were just the tool that he
used yeah to teach everybody else how to
be strong how to live with himself how
to love how to how to how to come back
how to you know yeah come back King man
you show you show you show you a young
black Street [ __ ] man how to come back
and be and be cool with losing your
money and live over yourself
yeah man so you
man you supposed to win through that mic
yeah unfortunately you were the catalyst
and God used you for that no tell tune
and that's what you did for me I look at
you and say man that man teaches me how
to live with myself how to forgive
myself
you know people commit suicide people go
on drugs people become homeless all of
that stuff because they don't know me
kill myself then I think some dark [ __ ]
a mother damn that I can [ __ ] that girl
I think that's dark shift4 I can kill
myself and suffer one [ __ ] that girl
before I go and that [ __ ] is very I mean
these are natural instincts dude and
some people have higher levels than
others
oh my god [ __ ] you know higher levels
huh yeah I mean some people are just
hot-blooded as my grandmother once
wisely put you know mm [ __ ] dude that
was so incredibly put Mike what you said
about Mike you were supposed to go
through that man all the highs all the
devastating lows man some people never
make it through half of your life from
that experience yeah I'm sure I didn't
want to be back in jail one day I was in
[ __ ] prison I was locked up and they
um I still had these are these people
they had a bunch of powers a squad
magnet I still had to do this anywhere I
got locked up right so they brought the
interview in there where I support my
son in there I did the interview on the
front cover the magazine while I was in
jail
it's crazy bro yeah it was just to trip
I'm sorry laughs what was going on I
feed him I said what was that going
through back then well I wasn't so mad
about law I was rich I was worth it had
everything I wanted what was I mad about
that's something what the [ __ ] was I mad
about you know what man I've no reason
man but that's also a great lesson and
money doesn't bring you the peace that
you think it might you know that so many
people believe if I have you know if I
make this much money my life will be
better my life will be perfect I'll be
happy I'll be at peace and it's not true
because your happiness and your joy and
your love for yourself has to come from
within no matter where you fill it yeah
the money the jury the women the cars
right nothing das is the biggest glutton
is taking everything is enough yeah but
you know what Mike I think I think you
probably felt you probably felt used you
know yes absolutely yeah when you when
you feel used
there's nothing you can give me because
because I feel like you only given it to
me because you're using me you know I'm
saying so there's no money amount of
money or fame you can give me because
you using me you know what I'm saying
and we and when you young and you don't
have nothing you let somebody use you
for somebody else yeah I'm gonna let you
use me so that I can help them if you
look at the grand scheme matter of it
you didn't get nothing out of it yeah
they used you and they used you you some
Sam and that was just a good heart but
I'm telling you this for sure you
outlived a lot of [ __ ] that
wasn't supposed to you wasn't supposed
to outlive them no down you know now
lived a whole bunch of [ __ ]
health-wise why they bullshitting all
kind of different right ways so the only
buddy know would like guy you know me
but you definitely a great teacher man
you taught me a lot and uh you know keep
on being Mike Tyson have you well Mike
it's been awesome man thank you for
coming on the show you left Mike all day
on this
man we could man are there any shoutouts
anything you want to let everybody know
you got going on right now what are you
doing oh man I got a shout-out my man
Eddie Murphy I did a movie with Eddie
Murphy coming out called Dolomites it's
the roof story or Udyr Udyr anymore
that's I was a kid with the monkey name
again way down in the jungle deep he's
always be a bad [ __ ] in the
movie kicking ass that's awesome if any
more feet he's still a big force in
Hollywood huh Eddie Murphy is huge in
Hollywood you know he only do invent
films you don't see him do films all the
time he might disappear for three or
four years and come back his films or
events yeah man I got my special coming
out it's called only one mic yeah and
they're talking about Donald Trump
totally about everybody I love that dude
talkin real talking real [ __ ] about
everything and everybody you know what I
mean when does that drop yeah that's
gonna drop on Netflix in April this is
awesome a big one here it's gonna be
bigger than the old Jay case I love it
bro can't wait for that it's gonna be
big man and thank you guys man thanks
for my Mike Tyson gloves and hell yeah
dude Mike I'll be back to see you man
much love oh gee what do you do man you
downtime what I do on my downtime my god
I really really uh I got a man cave at
the house and it's slash my office I do
everything in there you know what I mean
sometime I do promos all day for my
shows on the weekend take my kids to
school early in the morning they go to
Buckley I take my daughter's of school
you know early they are 12 and 14 yeah
girls man so I I love being with them
they keep me young and excited I go to
their soccer games and stuff so just
being a dad man just trying to do the
right thing trying to stay out the
penitentiary and
you know try to pay these few little
bills man they got they got some sales
over at Target I'm gonna go over and try
to catch them about two weeks oh man
this we right here man this is them my
gifts these are them day days I don't
want to call them to Mike Epps because
that's the charge but these are the data
is maplewood
you know I mean I like the package
yeah the package is nice right yeah for
sure I like maple wood yeah
Luther Campbell's movie nasty as they
want to be to Luke Skywalker no I'm
gonna play him I'm producing the movie
though wit Luke but this is the story at
a Luke Skywalker movie member Luke look
at the man and mime are those guys
cowboy doll I mention a name to those
guys Liberty City
yeah it's gonna be big awesome man well
you'll have to come back Mike okay I
appreciate you guys man god bless you
may be thinner edited me right man you
know they got all these movements going
on until next time I Love You L'Oreal
peace
[Music]